تساؤلات عده حول وادي الرمل الذي عاد
للجريان بعد سنوات من التوقف حول تاريخه
وسرميته وامكانيه استمرار جريانه الزميله
العنود العبدلي تعرفنا اكثر اولا على وادي
الرمان
كما يعرف اصبح حديث الناس بعد جريان
تاريخي على وقع الامطار الغزيره التي
شهدتها محافظه عنيزه بمنطقه القصيم وسط
السعوديه وادي الرمم مشاهدينا هو احد
والشواهد التاريخيه في هضبه نجد ويعد
الوادي متنزها عاما لاهالي المنطقه بعد ان
ردد الكثيرون بانها او بانها المره الاولى
التي يفيض فيها الوادي منذ 14 عاما لماذا
سمي وادي الرمه بهذا الاسم خبير الارصاد
الجويه الدكتور خالد الزعاق قال ان تسميه
جاءت من الفعليه رمم اي ياكلوا كل جالسين
في طريقه ويقع معظم حوض وادي الرمه
بينما تقع اطرافه جنوب منطقه حائل وشرق
منطقه المدينه المنوره وشمالي وشمال غربي
منطقه الرياض ويبلغ طول هذا الوادي
مشاهدينا نحو 1200 كم تقريبا ويجعله اطول
الاو انت في شبه الجزيره العربيه
تتحدث عن اكبر ظاهره علميه كما وصفت تحدث
في الجزيره العربيه وهي جريان الماء في
وادي الرمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكبر ظاهره علميه تحدث عندنا في الجزيره
العربيه جريان وادي الرمه ولهذا يسمى بشيخ
الاوديه علاوه على ذلك انه من معشوقنا لقد
سمعنا باوصاف له كملت فصرنا ما سمعنا
واحيانا من قبل رؤيته منا محبته والاذن
تعشق قبل العين
احيانا فهو معشوقنا وعلاقتنا مع وادي
الرمه علاقه حياتيه وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
الحياتيه يعمل على رفع مياه الابار
الجوفيه
ويقلل ملوحه هذه الابار علاوه على ذلك انه
يجدد خصوبه الارض وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
النفسيه تتلخص في اننا سعداء عندما نشاهد
هذا الوادي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانا امثل العشق المنطقه لهذا الوادي فانا
انام واكل واشرب بجانبي هذا الوادي كانت
مسائله الركباني تخبرنا عن جابر بن حيان
افضل الخبر ثم التقينا والله ما سمعت اذني
باحسن مما رات
بصل
[موسيقى]
من عنيزه ينضم الينا نائب رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبد الله المسلم
الدكتور حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
دكتور ما تشاهده اليوم في وادي الرمه يعني
هو بالفعل
يعني منظر مختلف تماما عن مكان عليه قبل
14 سنه ولا نحن امام تغير حقيقي اليوم
ربما في في حاله هذا الوادي وعوده جريانه
لمكان عليه قبل سنين طويله
اسعد الله مساء الجميع
الوادي في هذا العام ممكن يصنف بانه جريان
معتدل الى متوسط تقريبا
مقارنه
بالجريان الذي حدث عام 1982 1402 ايضا
جريان عام
1429 كان اقوى
واكثر من هذا الجريان الذي اقف امامه الان
وارى الضعف بدا
بالوادي
والجريان همم
يتكرر كل تقريبا
20 25 سنه هذا الكلام قبل عقدين من الزمن
اما في هذه العقود بدا يتكرر وربما نستطيع
القول انه بكل 10 سنوات همم يجري جريانا
كاملا ونقصد بجريان الكامل من اهالي وادي
الرمه من مرتفعات حره بني رشيد شرقي منطقه
المدينه حتى شرق القصيم حيث يحير عند
اعتاب نفود اتويرات
رصدت كذلك في في كثير من المناطق المملكه
مع الموجات المطيره اللي استمرت لوقت يعني
وكذلك في الربع الخالي
دكتور انت شايف انه اليوم المنطقه يعني
تغادر حاله مناخيه وتدخل في حاله مناخيه
اخرى
اخي خالد الناس تنسى ولكن القى الارقام
والقيم وسجلات المناخيه المسجله منذ اكثر
من 70 عاما في محطات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه خاصه المحطات التي انشات في
اورامكو تثبت ان كل ما يجري خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالحالات المطريه كل ما يجري هو
طبيعي ولا يمكن ان يعزع الى تغير مناخي
عدا عنصر درجه الحراره وهو الامر واضح جدا
ان هناك تغير مناخي على مستوى العالم
يتعلق بارتفاع درجه الحراره في كل الفصول
الاربعه وعليه الشتاء الذي نعيشه في
العقود المتاخره ليس
كاستهات التي كانت قبل الاربعين سنه اما
الحالات المطريه التي عشناها هذا العام
فهي في سياق والرتم المعتاد اللي امطار
في هذا الفصل وبفصل الشتاء او موسم
الامطار ولكن الناس تنسى وبالمناسبه هذه
الحاله تعتبر حاله في الواقع ايضا تاريخيه
استثنائيه التي سميت بحاله مدرار واستمرت
لعشره ايام شاملات كل مناطق المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبعض دول الخليج
يعني مثلا
المرتفعات في مكه وفي جده همم اكتساؤها
بالخضره في الربع الخالي في كثير من
المناطق باستمرار الامطار كلها اثاره ردود
افعال من الناس همم حول بالفعل انه احنا
امام تغير مناخي كبير والبعد ربط بينها
وبين حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم بان
همم بعوده هذه الصحراء مروجا وانهارا بما
في معنا هل هناك علاقه بين الامرين دكتور
عبد الله من خلال متابعتك يعني
العالم كله يمر بحاله من التغير المناخ
المتطرفه
حتى تعود ارض العرب مروجا وانهارا وهذه
البساط الاخضر الذي نشاهده في تلال وجبال
منطقه مكه في الواقع ايضا معتاد ولكن بين
فتره وفتره طويله جدا لان الكاميرات قابله
40 و 50 سنه لم تكون موجوده ومتوفره عند
كل الناس
وليس هذه المناظر التي تسر الناظرين
ونشاهدها في المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي فعلا
نادره الحدود ولكن همم يعني اعيد واقول ان
الحالات المطريه في المملكه الى الان لم
نجد لعاصله بينها وبين تغير المناخ ولا
يعني ذلك ان التغير المناخي العالمي لن
يؤثر على الامطار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولكن انماذج المناخيه
ما في اي دراسه
لسنوات قادمه لحاله المناخ بناء على ما
يحدث او ما حدث مثلا
عن التنبؤات في عنصر المطر اذا بعض
النماذج المناخيه توحي الى ان الامطار سوف
تزود في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ما بين
15 الى 20 بالمئه وبعض النماذج همم تقول
عكس ذلك انها سوف تنقص لذلك لا نستطيع ان
نتتك على هذه التوقعات بعيده المدى فيما
يتعلق بانصر المطر اما عنصر درجه الحراره
في الناس كلهم يشعرون ان درجه الحراره قدر
ارتفعات واختلفت عما كانت عليه فيما سبق
شكرا دكتور عبد الله المسند نائب رئيس
جمعيه الطقس والمناخ من عنيزه